To recap, in this lesson,
we zoomed in on the first step of our pipeline,
loading and transforming data with Power Query.
First, we learned how to access the data and we
learned how to do this using the Get Data feature.
We looked at the options you have at your fingertips to
pull data together from Power BI and we discussed
some creative approaches you can take if Power BI doesn't
already have a ready connection for what you need out of the box.
Such as web scraping or leveraging an open database connector.
Then we learned how to tidy up the data to make it easier for you, your end-users,
and Power BI to easily find and use the data you need.
We saw that the initial data we get from a query
before we've tidied up can have a whole bunch of
issues and we use some basic transformations to
make sure our data is nicely cleaned and without any clutter.
This queues up our data for either data model usage or
the more significant transformations we'll go through in an upcoming lesson.
Another important part of preparing our data involves identifying and using
the correct data types so that calculations and visualizations work as intended.
In this lesson, we learned how to use
the correct data types such as texturing, fixed decimal, date,
and true-false to constrain your data and ensure that these fields
will calculate correctly in your data model and resulting report.
Finally, we learned how to use the M formula language to
make corrections after the fact once we've made some preliminary transformations.
If you followed along with all of this,
you now know how to load and tidy up your data so
it's ready for the more advanced transformation wizardry we'll be doing later,
and so it has the right structure and data types we need for the final report.